[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend heute wm-spielfrei darum
eine extra Portion Wintersport später
mit der Kristin
guten Abend wir blicken jetzt auf unsere
Themen an diesem Donnerstag
eine Richterin Soldaten Polizisten unter
Terrorverdacht warum sich der Staat
schwer damit tut Extremisten aus seinem
Dienst herauszuhalten
[Musik]
es jault es piepst was am warntag
funktioniert hat und was nicht
und der tiefe Fall des wirecard-chefs
jetzt muss markus Braun vor Gericht
erklären wieso seine Bilanzen
Milliardenlöcher hatten
[Musik]
nach der Riesenrad hier in der
reichsbürgersszene hinterfragen die
Sicherheitsbehörden wie es eigentlich
sein kann dass in Deutschland Elite
Soldaten oder Polizisten extremistische
Pläne wie einen bundestagsangriff oder
einen regierungssturz mittragen gut
möglich dass es nach Auswertung von
Computern und Mobiltelefonen weitere
Festnahmen gibt zum aktuellen Stand
Christian Volk
eine Außenstelle des Bundesgerichtshofs
in Karlsruhe auch heute werden hier
mutmaßlich gewaltbereite Reichsbürger
dem Ermittlungsrichter vorgeführt 23 der
25 Festgenommenen sitzen mittlerweile in
Untersuchungshaft etwa Birgit malsack
winkemann bis 2021 für die AFD im
Bundestag danach wieder Richterin am
Berliner Landgericht gegen den Willen
der Senatsverwaltung da wir gestern bei
diesen Abgründen einer terroristischen
Vereinigung auch gesehen haben dass dort
Mitarbeiter Mitarbeiter des öffentlichen
Dienstes betroffen waren ist es für mich
ein anliegendes wir Verfassungsfeinde
aus dem öffentlichen Dienst schneller
entfernen können weil wir verhindern
müssen dass der öffentliche Dienst das
sehr stark von innen heraus sabotiert
werden kann die Innenministerin will
deshalb noch in diesem Jahr einen
Gesetzentwurf vorlegen doch eine
Umsetzung könnte schwierig werden
Richter Soldaten Polizisten sind als
Staatsdiener verpflichtet
verfassungstreut zu sein aber diese
verfassungstreu zu überprüfen ist immer
eine schwierige Einzelfallentscheidung
weil es ein Überprüfung der Gesinnung
ist und die ist extrem schwierig
ebenfalls in Haft ein aktiver und zwei
ehemalige Bundeswehrsoldaten wegen
solcher Verbindungen fordern die Chefs
der Sicherheitsbehörden in Zukunft
schärfere Überprüfungen in solchen
Zeiten wo wir auch sehr stark als
Sicherheitskräfte gefordert sind muss
man sich darauf verlassen können dass
alle uneingeschränkt hinter der Freiheit
demokratischen Grundordnung stehen das
heißt auch dass man eine entsprechenden
Check macht also eine sogenannte
Sicherheitsüberprüfung und ich denke
dass dort wo es noch nicht gemacht wird
wir das auch in absehbarer Zeit
einführen werden in Thüringen suchten
die Ermittler auch heute nach weiteren
Beweisen und Waffen in den kommenden
Tagen sollen außerdem die
beschlagnahmten Computer Datenträger und
Mobiltelefone ausgewertet werden
heute
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in Berlin
die letzte in diesem Jahr aber anders
als in den vergangenen corona-jahren hat
die Gipfel Aufmerksamkeit abgenommen
trotzdem sind infolge von Pandemie und
Energiekrise schwierige Entscheidungen
zu fällen und wenn Bund und Länder über
Kreuz liegen dann geht es fast immer ums
Geld um Milliarden wie beim 49 Euro
Ticket oder den 200 €
energieentlastungen für Studenten
theokoll verfolgt ist für uns in Berlin
Theo der vielleicht prominenteste
streitpunkt ist es 49 Euro Ticket wann
kommt es oder kommt es überhaupt also ob
es überhaupt kommt das dürfte sich
gerade heute abend entscheiden denn die
Ministerpräsidenten argumentieren dass
die versprochenen staatlichen Gelder
also die drei Milliarden Euro unter
anderem wegen gestiegener Energiekosten
gar nicht mehr ausreichen sollte der
Bund also wirklich noch einmal
zusätzliches Geld locker machen dann
könnte das 49 € Ticket im Frühjahr
beginnt insgesamt ist heute
offensichtlich der Tag an dem Bund und
Länder doch noch mal den rechten Sch
etwas genauer anlegen und das könnte
bedeuten dass ich auch die ein oder
andere Wohltat vielleicht den Luft
auflöst beispielsweise weiß keiner so
recht wie man die versprochenen 200 Euro
für Studierende überhaupt ausbezahlen
soll und selbst wenn dann in Stunden
allein pro Person 60 Euro
Verwaltungskosten auf der Tagesordnung
ist heute auch das große Thema
Flüchtlinge aber da geht es dann
ausnahmsweise weniger ums Geld als viel
mehr um die zu hohe Zahl viele Kommunen
sagen sie sind jetzt schon in der
Belastungsgrenze und sie fordern vom
Bund dafür zu sorgen dass weniger
Flüchtlinge über die sogenannte
Balkanroute kommen da ist dann weiteres
Geld fast noch die leichtere Aufgabe
Theo danke für die aktuellen
Informationen nach Berlin
bundesweiter waren Tag heute in
Deutschland das Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz bewertet ihn trotz
Lücken als Erfolg die Behörde hatte wie
angekündigt um 11 Uhr landesweit Alarm
ausgelöst und viele Handys begannen dann
zu schrillen laut und zwar durch das
neues selber broadcasting System sie
holten und im Radio und Fernsehen gab es
warn Informationen Heiko Rahms hat jetzt
die Einzelheiten
probewarnung bundesweiter waren Tag 2022
mit dieser Nachricht meldete sich heute
erstmals das selbe broadcast-system bei
den Handynutzern doch nicht jedes Gerät
schlug Alarm
bei mir ist leider gar nichts passiert
total merkwürdig ich habe drauf gewartet
und um Punkt 11 Uhr leider nichts und ja
Handy hat deutlich gebietig ich habe das
hier gemerkt in der Hosentasche das war
wirklich
auf Social Media berichteten Nutzer das
bei einigen Geräten die warn-apps Nina
und katwarn versagten nicht das einzige
Problem so eine Expertin es wurde schon
großer Teil der Bevölkerung erreicht
aber eben noch nicht alle gerade beim
iPhone gab es noch an einigen Stellen
Probleme
auch nicht alle Android Geräte wurden
erreicht insgesamt war es ein sehr
durchwachsenes Bild
dennoch ist das Bundesamt für
Katastrophenschutz zufrieden
nach unseren ersten Vorläufern
Erkenntnissen war der bundesweite
warntag ein Erfolg das Zusammenspiel der
einzelnen Systeme hat gut funktioniert
das heißt nicht dass es nicht an der
einen oder anderen Stelle noch
Verbesserungsbedarf geben mag
mittlerweile besser zu hören sind die
Sirenen im Aartal diese hier wurde heute
in Betrieb genommen
jetzt zu einem der größten
wirtschaftskandale in Deutschland die
Pleite des Finanzdienstleisters Wirecard
lange galt es Unternehmen als
Hoffnungsträger zeitweise war es sogar
im DAX also dort wo Deutschlands
wichtigste Börsenwerte abgebildet sind
dann kamen Berichte über zweifelhafte
Transaktionen auf Milliarden
verschwanden spurlos unternehmensprüfer
und Bank auf sich hatten versagt
tausende Anleger haben ihr Geld verloren
und jetzt stehen x wirecardchef markus
Braun und zwei mit Angeklagte vor
Gericht aus München Petra Neubauer
der Andrang ist gewaltig die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind es auch so
beginnt der wirecard-prozess erst mit
gut 45 Minuten Verspätung im Mittelpunkt
markus Braun einst gefeierter Chef des
ehemaligen Dax-Konzerns nun gemeinsam
mit zwei ex-managern auf der Anklagebank
dem Angeschuldigten braun werfen wir den
bandenmäßigen gewerbsmäßigen Betrug vor
Marktmanipulation und Treue und
Bilanzfälschung auch als unrichtige
Darstellung bezeichnet vor Wirecard galt
als Börsenliebling bis das Bild des
erfolgreichen Konzerns im Juni 2020
zerbricht markus Braun muss bekannt
geben dass 1,9 Milliarden Euro
verschwunden sind angeblich Geld aus dem
sorentablen Asiengeschäft doch laut
Anklage war alles nur vorgetäuscht mit
dem Ziel ein Unternehmen das längst
nicht so erfolgreich war wie es sich
nach außen hin gerne dargestellt hat
erfolgreicher da stehen zu lassen so
habe Wirecard an immer neue Kredite
kommen wollen
markus Braun sieht sich dagegen als
Opfer betrogen von ehemaligen Kollegen
wie dem untergetauchten Jan marschalik
er gilt als eine der Schlüsselfiguren in
diesem Skandal schriftlich erklären
Brauns Verteidiger dr markus Braun war
in die Machenschaften die ausschließlich
der Veruntreuung von Geldern der
Wirecard AG dienten nicht involviert und
hatte hiervon auch keine Kenntnis es ist
ein Mammutprozess hundert
Verhandlungstage sind bislang terminiert
um zumindest Brauns Rolle in diesem
wirtschaftskandal aufzuklären
seit fast drei Monaten gehen die
Menschen in Iran auf die Straße gegen
das Regime und das hat jetzt zum ersten
Mal einen Demonstranten hinrichten
lassen Außenministerin bärbock warf der
Führung in tehan Menschenverachtung vor
der 23-Jährige wurde in einem
Schnellverfahren wegen Kriegsführung
gegen Gott zum Tode verurteilt erklärte
die Justizbehörde Mosen Shikari soll
eine Straße blockiert und ein Mitglied
einer Miliz verletzt haben
jetzt zu einem spektakulären
Gefangenenaustausch zwischen Washington
und Moskau die in Russland inhaftierte
us-basketballerin Britney griner wurde
überraschend freigelassen Monate lang
wurde hinter den Kulissen hart gerungen
im Gegenzug ist ein berüchtigter
russischer Waffenhändler aus us-haft
entlassen worden aus Washington Benjamin
Daniel
sie ist sicher sie ist im Flieger sie
ist auf dem Weg nach Hause mit diesem
Tweet des US-Präsidenten startete
Amerika heute in den Tag
wird schon bald bei ihren Liebsten sein
wo sie die ganze Zeit schon hingehört
hätte wir haben lange auf diesen Tag
hing gearbeitet und nie aufgehört für
ihre pfeilassung zu kämpfen es waren
mühsame und intensive Verhandlungen
war im Februar wegen Besitzes von
cannabisöl in Moskau festgenommen worden
Anfang August an die Verurteilung zu 9
Jahren Haft zuletzt war die zweimalige
Olympiasiegerin von Moskau in ein
Straflager in die Republik mordovien
gebracht worden Russland erhöhte damit
den Druck offenbar erfolgreich
denn die USA haben im Austausch für
griner den berüchtigten Waffenhändler
Viktor gut freigelassen er soll weltweit
mit diversen Waffensystemen gehandelt
haben bis hin zu Boden luftraketen
deshalb wurde er in den USA zu 25 Jahren
Haft verurteilt
Britney griners Ehefrau ist dennoch
überglücklich aber sie mahnte auch dass
noch viele andere Amerikaner im Ausland
festgehalten würden
wir feiern das Britney nach Hause kommt
aber es gibt noch andere Familien die
durchmachen was ich in den letzten neun
Monaten durchgemacht habe und die ihre
Liebsten vermissen
beiden hat einen hohen Preis für griners
Freilassung bezahlt die
Verhandlungsmasse die ihr nun für andere
Amerikaner in russischer Haft wie den
ehemaligen US-Soldaten Paul Wielen hat
ist damit gewaltig gesunken
Russland verstärkt weiterhin seine
Angriffe in der Ostukraine Kriegsziel
Seiten nach wie vor auch die
annektierten Regionen zu befreien so
formulierte erste putinssprecher in
Moskau die russischen Angriffe sorgen
erneut für Stromausfälle auch in einer
Kinderklinik 140 km von Kiew entfernt
über den Kriegsalltag dort unsere
Reporter Hannah Hebestreit
wegen der russischen Angriffe sind die
oberen Etagen der Kinderklinik von
citomia geschlossen Chefarzt der propoli
hat den Betrieb nach unten verlegt der
Krieg nimmt keine Rücksicht auf die Not
der Kinder immer wieder unterbricht
Luftalarm auch hier die Behandlung
Kinder die alleine laufen können gehen
selbst in den Luftschutzkeller Kinder
die beatmet werden oder
Intensivpatienten sind können wir da
nicht hinbringen die schieben wir in den
Flur wo sie sicherer sind
auch Mascha und ihrem Baby gönnt der
Krieg keine Verschnaufpause die
18-Jährige ist aus einer russisch
besetzten Region zu Entbindung hierher
in die zentral Ukraine geflüchtet
in der Nacht mussten wir wegen des
luftalarms in den Keller keiner wusste
was passiert ich hatte große Angst wegen
meines Babys ich mache mir um ihn viel
mehr Sorgen als um mich selbst ich hoffe
dass das bald vorbei ist
ihre Ärztin erlebt auf der
Geburtenstation oft unmittelbar die
Folgen von Russlands Angriffskrieg
die Frauen sind gestresst wegen des
Krieges und weil sie ihre Heimat
verlassen mussten viele Babys kommen
früher auf die Welt und oft mit deutlich
weniger Gewicht als gut für sie ist
auch die Arbeitsbedingungen der
Mediziner werden schnell prekär wenn
sich plötzlich wieder russische Raketen
dem Krankenhaus
[Musik]
wir hatten schon mitten in den
Operationen Luftalarm und konnten unsere
Arbeit nicht unterbrechen zum Glück
haben wir Generatoren deshalb ist bei
uns das Licht noch nicht ausgegangen
die Mediziner sind froh dass sie auch
aus Deutschland mit gespendeten Geräten
unterstützt werden
in Brüssel ging es heute um die Frage ob
Reisen in Europa künftig noch
grenzenloser wird die EU-Innenminister
stimmten über die Erweiterung des
schengenraumes ab bislang sind 26 Länder
beteiligt an den Grenzen gibt es im
Normalfall keine Passkontrollen
unstrittig war dass Kroatien hinzukommt
anders sei es mit Bulgarien und Rumänien
aus Isabel Schäfers berichtet
es klingt fast als würde hier in Brüssel
heute ein Preis und vor allem auch ein
Trostpreis verliehen
den kroatischen Bürgern möchte ich sagen
willkommen und Glückwunsch zur Aufnahme
in den Schengenraum ich möchte mich aber
auch an die Bürger aus Rumänien und
Bulgarien richten ihr hättet es auch
verdient Schengen Mitglied zu werden
Kroatien ist drin bekam heute das
einstimmige Votum für den Schengen
Beitritt ab dem 1 Januar entfallen also
die Grenzkontrollen zu den
EU-Nachbarländern
Rumänien und Bulgarien hingegen haben es
nicht geschafft noch vor Beginn der
Sitzung war es der österreichische
Innenminister der beiden Ländern vorerst
die Hoffnung nahm
ja ich werde heute gegen die
schengenerweiterung und Rumänien
Bulgarien Stimmen ich halte es für
falsch es ist falsch dass ein System das
an vielen Stellen nicht funktioniert an
dieser Stelle auch noch vergrößert wird
nach Meinung Österreichs funktioniert
die Kontrolle an den EU-Außengrenzen
nicht Bulgarien tue nicht genug gegen
illegale Migration zu viele Flüchtlinge
kämen unregistriert in Österreich an
Bulgarien ist nicht verantwortlich für
die internen Probleme Österreichs aber
wir sind bereit gemeinsam an einer
Lösung zu arbeiten es gab Kriterien die
Sie zu erfüllen hatten alle drei haben
sie gleichermaßen erfüllt dann wäre es
nur folgerichtig gewesen dann auch allen
starken gleichermaßen das zu gewähren
ich glaube auch dass es zu einer
verbesserten Sicherheit innerhalb der EU
beigetragen hätte die
schengenerweiterung wird Thema bleiben
genauso wie die weiterhin ungelösten
Fragen zur Migration
schon wieder sind klimaaktivisten der
sogenannten letzten Generation in die
Sicherheitsbereiche deutscher Flughäfen
eingedrungen am Hauptstadtflughafen BER
lief der Flugbetrieb normal weiter
nachdem Aktivisten daran gehindert
worden waren auf das Rollfeld zu
gelangen zuvor klebten sie sich auf dem
roll-vorfeld Fest in München gelangten
die Aktivisten eben bis aufs Rollfeld
bei einigen Flügen kam es daraufhin zu
geringen Verspätungen
so jetzt mal kein Fußball sondern einem
richtig schönen Erfolg in Biathlon
Christin und das tut richtig gut selbst
beim Zuschauen noch nie zuvor unter den
Top Ten und nun endlich ganz oben auf
Olympiasiegerin Denise Hermann Wick
gewann zum ersten Mal einen
Weltcup-Rennen in Hochfilzen Österreich
die 7,5 km der Lohn für eine fehlerfreie
Vorstellung
Denise hermannweg freut sich über ihr
Meisterstück hier beim Sprint in
Hochfilzen
die die Horror Strecke für mich so ein
bisschen und Horror Schießstand der
letzten Jahre und dass ich da heute so
mein Drama überwunden habe das weiß ich
natürlich besonders der Schlüssel zum
Erfolg das fehlerfrei schießen 20 Schuss
20 Treffer für die Einzel
Olympiasiegerin auf der Strecke heute
versteckte Eisplatten vorsicht ist
geboten dennoch die 33-Jährige versucht
den Skilaufen zu lassen überzeugt mit
der siebt schnellsten Laufzeit und bei
der Kombination aus laufen und schießen
ist hermannweg heute die beste 18
Sekunden ihr Vorsprung auf die
zweitplatzierte Marketer davidoffer aus
Tschechien auf Rang 3 die Französin
Julia Simon
große Freude auch bei den Fußballerinnen
des FC Bayern München vor heimischer
Rekordkulisse von 24.000 Fans
triumphierten sie im vierten
Vorrundenspiel in der Champions League
über die favorisierten Spanierinnen vom
FC Barcelona mit drei zu eins und peilen
nun selbstbewusst das Viertelfinale der
Königsklasse an
[Applaus]
Ruhetag bei der Fußball-WM der Männer in
Katar und Spanien hat sich nach dem
Achtelfinale aus von Trainer Luis
Enrique getrennt hierzulande bleibt ja
der Bundestrainer aber die DFL und der
DFB befinden sich personell durchaus im
Umbruch
Hans-Joachim Watzke nicht nur sehr
einflussreich sondern auch viel gefragt
in diesen turbulenten Tagen bei den
Deutschen spitzensportverbänden als DFL
Aufsichtsratschef deutet er jetzt an
dass die Nachfolge der zurückgetretenden
Geschäftsführerin Donata Hopfen auch in
einer Doppelspitze liegen könne zur
Neubesetzung des Amtes bzw der Ämter von
Oliver Bierhoff meint Watzke es wäre
schön wenn wir vor Weihnachten eine
Lösungen hätten aber da weiß ich nicht
ob das überhaupt realisierbar ist ich
weiß noch nicht ob das sein muss weil
wir sollten jetzt einfach Genauigkeit
vor Schnelligkeit setzen das zweieinhalb
stundenige Gespräch gestern mit Hansi
Flick hat er dfb-vize als er konstruktiv
empfunden
er stand überhaupt nicht so Diskussion
dass es das eine Trennung von von Hansi
Flick in irgendeiner Weise auf der
Tagesordnung stand weitere interner
wollte Watzke aber nicht preisgeben
geheimnisvolle Weihnachtszeit dazu passt
auch danke Christin dass es winterlich
kalt wird die Details hat dazu gleich im
Wetter ist in terli um 22 Uhr
einschaltempfehlung des heute journal
mit mariierter Slomka morgen an dieser
Stelle Barbara hallweg danke fürs
zuschauen haben Sie noch einen
entspannten Abend tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter es wird kälter in
den nächsten Tagen und auch Schnee kommt
dazu das liegt an diesem Tief hier was
vom Atlantik übers Mittelmeer weiter
zieht und nach Norden sich verlagert die
kalte Luft hier an saugt und das
bedeutet dann Schnee hauptsächlich im
Süden und im Osten Deutschlands schauen
wir auf die nächste Nacht und da gibt's
im Südwesten aufkommenden Schneefall
ansonsten der Schnee im Osten der
verabschiedet sich dazwischen klartes
teilweise auf es bildet sich dichter
Nebel und glatt wird es so oder so auf
den Straßen des Schnee oder auch über
fremde Nässe denn die Temperaturen gehen
zurück bis auf -6 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein 0 im Osten und ein
grad ganz im Westen morgen dann weitere
Schneefälle ganz im Süden Deutschland
sonst ist es trocken im Westen scheint
die Sonne im Osten ist es meistens dicht
bewölkt bei höchsten Temperaturen von
minus ein bis vier Grad es wird also ein
kalter Tag ja und die nächsten Tage
weitere Schneefälle am Samstag im Süden
und im Osten am Sonntag verlagert sich
das allmählich weiter nordwärts und am
Montag auch etwas in den Westen
Temperaturen -3 bis +3 Grad ein schöner
Abend